everyone I am I am robot overlord xt
4000 but I searched my database of human
names and I want to know you I want unit
I'm sorry I'm so I'm through hey
everybody people of Earth I think that's
pretty standard pretty standard greeting
when there are so many of you here
people of Earth to begin again I am our
x 4000 a pretty standard robot overlord
prototype but I search the database name
and make you more comfortable with me
being your you know domineering robot
overlord type call me Henry I thought
about you know Henry Hank I don't want
to hang because I'm still in charge okay
I'm wearing the metal pants that brings
me to Henry's rules for planet Earth Wow
one this is going to seem a little out
of left field foot up everybody here
name's Susan you're gonna have to go and
by that I mean we're gonna kill you and
we're going to use Susan bones to make a
huge dial phone which I'm going to play
at the end of the year a big big
extravaganza we're thinking Susan
Palooza I know a lot of people named
Susan here are panicking but you're
gonna like these other rules too I need
some new notes hampton min to newman o's
organic oreos and i want them in my
visit right now that's a little lap I
know every language I'm like 3pm how you
can speak that Ewok language I'm just
referencing pop culture to make you more
comfortable I'm actual no more loud gum
chewing and I see about 17 people trying
to swallow that gum I actually already
took enter named you're going to be
boiled with the citizens some of you
were named Susan and you were chewing a
gum loudly we're gonna boil you and then
boil
those runs on ps4 this out a lot of this
is going to be clear as we go but in the
meantime if somebody would get me not a
white hammock with like a green or
orange nylon hammock that's how I do I
wouldn't sleep in that